the astros are going to be facing a
rookie right-hander his name is
lj newsom this will be his fourth career
start as he takes on the astros as
george springer begins this one with a
solid single to center field welcome
back to the lineup george
he is now 11 for his last 20 in the
first inning
jose altuve will stand in for the astros
swinging a high fly ball left center
field into the gap over
is kyle lewis calling for it he's a
quarterback out there and he makes the
catch michael brantley will stand in the
designated hitter
little ground ball towards the right
side backhand to second for one
brantley's going to beat the relay
so one on two weights and here is third
baseman alex bregman a little
topper towards the middle the diamond
past j.p crawford into center michael's
going to challenge kyle lewis and
brantley is safe
good heads up base running there putting
runners on first and third
and the astros have runners at the
corners with two out for kyle tucker
there's a sharply hit base hit into the
outfield
rbi number 42 kyle tucker has the astros
on top
one to nothing and now it's julie
guriel's turn swinging a ground ball
back up the middle but right there
second baseman ty france he's got it to
throw to first
and it's in time to get guriel for the
astros robert valdez four and three at
3.82 era in 10 games nine starts
and he'll face jp crawford to start
things off for seattle swinging a
chopper past the third baseman bregman
into left field to base it for jp
right away mariners have the tying run
aboard it so the lead off man
on for ty france this one chopped to the
left side
tough short hop for bregman alex makes
the play now the mariners have the time
run aboard in
scoring position here is center fielder
kyle lewis it's a fly ball in the right
field that sends reddick back to the
track to the wall
josh makes a jumping catch and bumps
against the wall right field crawford
doesn't not tag
so a loud out off the bat of kyle lewis
for out number two
that'll bring up third baseman kyle
sager there's a swing and a fly ball
deep to the right field reddick going
back this one is off the base of the
fence ronnie third heading home crawford
will score
kyle seeger with a two out rbi double
ties the game at one to one he's in
scoring position
now for luis torrens to catch her and
that's a ground ball
up the middle backhanded by altuve to
his right to jump through the first and
it's in time
excellent play by altuve to his right
patented jump throw
to first base to in the inning both
teams scoring in the first inning since
then both starters have retired the last
seven men they faced
here's bregman swinging a line drive
diving catch it short j.p
crawford way to his right into the air
robbing alex bregman of a base hit my
goodness
save that piece of videotape holy
mackerel the astros now have runners on
it first and third with
two outs better will be right fielder
josh reddick swung on and it's popped up
again shallow left center field cutting
across fraley calling for it jake is
there
and fraley makes the catch and newsom
does it the lj way he gets
himself out of a jam here in the top of
the fourth two on
two away and the better will be
designated hitter tim lopes and the
mariners have the go
ahead run 90 feet away and kyle seeger
fastball grounded to the right side
altuve there
down to one knees fields it and throws
out lopes for the third out so nice job
by from valdez there
strange a couple of runners in scoring
position now the mariners have runners
on it first and second with two outs
but now the mariners best hitter all
year kyle lewis will bat and that's a
ground ball
and caught by altuve flips to second to
get the force
and the inning draws to a close so
valdez works around
two base runners during this offensive
stretch where the astros have averaged
just over two runs a game for the last
eight
not exactly like they're facing cy young
award candidates sadler back up on the
hill facing michael brantley
and that's hit in the air pretty deep to
right it sends back irvin on the warning
track looking up and that ball is gone
that's what we needed a little motivator
michael brantley
and the astros lead it 2-1 maybe we just
needed to light that spark a little bit
runners at second and third now
that pitch gets through the catcher
terrence and that is a gift for the
astros
in comes kyle tucker to score it's now
three to one astros
martine maldonado two on with two outs
and martine looking to end an 0 for 19.
and maldonado drills this one deep to
left center field
see you later a three-run home run for
martine maldonado
that's how you end in 0 for 19 and the
astros lead
is six to one from valdez six innings a
one run ball so far
swinging a miss lopes goes down from
valdez working into the seventh inning
again tonight
picks up strikeout number six strikes
out fraley for the third time
back-to-back strikeouts on the fastball
from now with seven strikeouts in the
game
curveball called third strike fromber
strikes out the side
seven innings of one run baseball with
eight strikeouts
two outs for the mariners here in the
bottom of the night and here comes evan
white
strike three called 99 miles an hour
josh
james closes it out for the astros
who win it six to one